مباشره ننتقل واياكم الى كلمه لامين عمي
حلف الناتو ينسى سولتنبر في بروكسل
بان شركات استدرب العمل على تطوير برنامج
لعده سنوات من اجل اوكرانيا
في الجنوب من ضمنها انعدام الاستقرار
والارهاب
وروسيا والصين
لمعالجه كل هذه التحديات من الضروري ان
نستثمر المزيد في الشؤون الدفاعيه وفي
القامات واقعوا من الحلفاء ان يناقشوا
تعهدات الدفاعيه ب2% من الناتج المحليه
الاجمالي للدفاع
كارضيه وليس كالسقفان يوم الاربعاء
الهندي
الهادئ الشركاء الناتيه ينضمون الى
الاتحاد الاوروبيين ضمن اليابان واستراليا
وغيرها
وعواقب الحرب ضد اوكرانيا باتت عالميه وما
يحصل في اوروبا اليوم قد يحصل في شرق اسيا
غدا
ذلك ارحب بشركائنا ودعمهم القوي لاوكرانيا
اعلان اليابان مؤخرا عن اسهامها لمساعده
انها صندوقي مساعدتي اوكرانيا سوف اناقش
ان التعاونه في مجالات الامن السيبراني
والتكنولوجيا الجديده
ومكافحه المعلومات المضلله ان نعالج تحالف
الصين المستمر مع روسيا
وتوفير المساعدات الفتاكه لروسيا سيكون
خطا جسيما
وفي الوقت
تتحدى فيه روسيا واصيل النظام الدولي
والقيمه الديمقراطيه بات اكثر اهميه
الناقفه جنبا الى جنب كحلفاء في الناتوم
وبذلك انا مستعد جافع عن اسئلتكم
هل تتوقعون اعلان رئيس بوتين انه
سيضع الاسلحه النوويه التكتيكيه في
بيلاروسيا وهل تحصل ذلك في الايام القادمه
وتتوقعون ان يكون هناك اي تغييرات لموقفي
الناتو او تخطيطها نتيجه الاعلان او
التحركات او نقلا حصلت
اعلان الرئيس بوتين هو جزء من عندما من
الخطاب النووي الخطير والمتهور حيث يحاول
رئيس بوتين
استغلال الاسلحه انا وياك كاسلوب لي منعنا
من دمعي اوكرانيا من الدعم اوكرانيا
وكذلك على سالب القصر لوقف حلفائه انه
شركاها لدعمي اوكرانيا في حقها الدفاع عن
نفسها لن نشعر بالخوف او سوف نستمر بدعم
اوكرانيا بالتاكيد تبقى
متيقظه وان اراقب وما تقوم به روسيا
ولكن الى الان لم نشهد اي تغييرات في
موقفهم النووي
والذي يتطلب منا في دورنا التغيير موقفنا
نبقى متيقظين من اجل الدفاع عن كافه
الحلفاءنا ونراقبتي ما تقوم به روسيا ايضا
فيما يخص اي نشر او محتمل في بيلاروسيا
لو سمحت
توضح لنا فيما يخص فنلندا قلتم يوم غد
انكم سترحبون بفنلندا
كعضو الحادي والثلاثين هل كل شيء سينتهي
فنيا لعضويتها اما ستستغلون وجود الوزراء
لتحقيق ذلك كما اساله في المستقبل القريب
هل اتوقع انها تنشر اي معدات عسكريه او
دعم حدودي ماذا ستبعت الناتو لفنلندا في
الوقت القادم
هذه المعلومات حساسه
والافضل عدم استفزاز اي شخص او طرف
فله
من الغد فنلندا تصبح عضوا كاملا في
التحالف وشاركت في كافه اجتماعاتنا وهي
كرياتنا العسكريه
كعضو كامل
وهذا سيحصل غدا لان كافه الحلفاء الان
صدقوا على انضمام فنلندا وبروتوكولات
الانضمام مما يعني بين الشيء الوحيد
المتبقي او ما سيحصل غدا
هو ان تركيا والحليفه الاخيره الذي صادق
على انضمامي او اوراق انضمامي فنلندا
[موسيقى]
سيحصل في مقرنا غدا وبعد العشاء ساقوم
باخطار فنلندا وهم بالتالي سيودعون
وثقه الانضمام
ومن هناك
ستصبح فنلندا عضوا كاملا في تحالف
سوف يكون لدينا احتفال لرفع العلم خارج
هذا المبنى
في الساعه الثالثه والنصف يوم غد
وهذا اليوم يصادف
يوم ميلادي او تاسيس
حيث وقعت اتفاقيه في
راب نابريل 1949 فاضي يوم تاريخي ويوم
عظيم للتحالف وشرف كبير للترحيبي بتله
الذكاء عضو كامل
في شيء معنا غدا
ان اسال عن زميلنا الصحفي في روسيا هل
لديكم اي بيان حول ذلك الاعتقال وهل ستطرح
المساله من قبل وزراء الخارجيه يوم غدوا
حتى الاربعاء
وماذا بوسعي او يجب ان تفعل الناتجه
اولا اتوقع ان تطرح هذه المساله يوم غد
وثانيا انا انضم الى الولايات المتحده في
مطالبتهم لروسيا لاطلاق سراحي الصحفي
الاميركي ابا لضمان
حقه كعمل كصحفي واحترام حقوقهم
واقلقه جدا مهم جدا ان نحترم حريتي
الاعلام وحريه الصحفيين
وحريتي طرحي الاسئله والقيام بعملهم بذلك
انه طالب اطلاق سراحه الفوري
اذا تابعنا واياكم هذه الكلمه لامين عام
حلف الناتو
في بروكسل القلب انه يتوقع مناقشه
التعهدات في اجتماع الحلف القادم وبان ضمن
فنلندا للحلف غدا سيجعلها اكثر اماما
وستكون عضو كامل في حلف الناتو وقال بان
اي تقديم
لمساعدات صينيه عسكريه لروسيا سيكون خطا
جسيما كذلك قال بانهم سيستمرون في دعم
اوكرانيا وذكر ايضا بان موقف روسيا النووي
لم يتغير او لم يلاحظوا تغير في هذا
الموقف واخيرا قال بان تركيا وافقت على
انضمام فنلندا الى حلف الناتو